[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue le débrief des
questions au gouvernement une séance
avec plus d'une centaine de députés
présents dans l'hémicycle au lendemain
du déconfinement et une première
interpellation
quand les conseillers municipaux élus en
mars dernier pourront-ils se réunir et
lire les nouveaux maires c'est claudia
raw députés socialistes et apparentés
d'ille et vilaine qui pose la question à
l'issue du premier tour du scrutin le 15
mars dernier plus de 30 mille communes
ont un conseil municipal est lui au
complet dans le respect des précautions
sanitaires leur installation rapide est
souhaitable pour y élire les exécutifs
et engager des projets de mandature
suite à l'avis du conseil scientifique
le gouvernement vient de donner son feu
vert
je salue cette décision en sachant que
les nouveaux élus sont en attente de
précisions sur le calendrier
d'installation des conseils municipaux
le décret qui prévoit l'installation de
ces conseils municipaux sera pris enfin
sera publié le vendredi 15 mai il fixera
la date d'entrée en fonction des
conseillers municipaux et communautaires
le lundi 18 mai conformément à la loi du
23 mars
la première réunion du conseil municipal
qui permettra notamment d'élire le maire
et ses adjoints jeudi notamment d'élire
le maire et ses adjoints se tiendra dans
les cinq à dix jours après la date
d'entrée en fonction des conseillers
municipaux soit entre le samedi 23 mai
et le jeudi 28 mai autrement dit
mesdames et messieurs les députés au
plus tard le jeudi 28 mai trente mille
des 35000 communes françaises auront un
conseil municipal installé et un maire
et des adjoints élus dans les conditions
normales et je pense que nous pouvons
tous nous en féliciter restera
restera restera la question du deuxième
tour des élections municipales
le comité scientifique se prononcera sur
l'appréciation qu'ils portent au regard
de ses connaissances au moment où il
doit se prononcer et je crois que nous
aurons l'occasion d'en reparler il est
encore un peu tôt pour tirer toutes les
conséquences d'un avis dont nous ne
disposons pas dans l'hémicycle ce mardi
le thème du jour était bien évidemment
le déconfinement avec le retour à
l'école de près d'un million d'élèves
avec un protocole sanitaire très stricte
et très contraignant trop pour sabine
rubin député de la france en soumises de
seine-saint-denis elles reprochent un
manque d'empathie au ministre de
l'éducation nationale
comment feront ils pour consoler un
élève de maternelle ampleur
rien de prévu que feront les avantages
pour contenir les enfants en situation
de handicap qu'il consulte la fiche
parachuté hier après deux mois de
silence
alors certes si votre discours
maintenant mentionne l'aspect
psychologique le prendre soin des
enfants ce qui aurait dû guider votre
plan cette bienveillance de circonstance
arrive un peu tard
en réalité votre gestion technocratique
et erratique à 7 de cette reprise à mu
et l'inquiétude des parents une anxiété
permanente et vous voilà contraint de
déclarer de déclarer qu'il est moins
dangereux d'aller à l'école que de
rester c'est soir pour faire venir tous
les enfants un récent sondage indique en
effet que plus de 60% des familles ne
souhaitent pas envoyer leurs enfants à
l'école et davantage chez les classes
populaires
quelle ironie là encore même votre
objectif de justice sociale se voit
contrarier du mois dans l'idée il ya une
semaine vous même
est ce votre parti disait que les
communes ne rouvrirait pas que le 1er
oct au col sanitaire était trop
compliqué et bien ce matin le maire m'a
dit que le protocole sanitaire était
tout simplement exigeant mais qu'il
était content de l'avoir respecté et
j'ai vu des enfants heureux avec des
professeurs heureux en train d'accomplir
un objectif social fondamental alors en
matière sociale il ya ceux qui tiennent
des discours vous il y a ceux qui
agissent nous comment assurer la
sécurité des français
les transports en commun de plus en plus
nombreux c'est l'inquiétude d'eric
coquerel député la france insoumise
qu'allez vous mettre en oeuvre
concrètement ce pour assurer assurer la
sécurité sanitaire optimum des
travailleurs contraints de prendre les
transports en commun sachant qu'en plus
leur nom va grossir dans les jours à
venir
je m'adresse aux gouvernements car c'est
vous le donneur d'ordre celui qui a
choisi la date de déconfinement c'est
donc vous qui n'avez pas le droit à
l'erreur et bien évidemment cette
question ne remet pas en question les
agents et cheminots que vous avez
souhaité il y à peu privés de leur
régime de retraite tellement il était
privilégiée nous avons conçu une
stratégie qui permet d'avoir le moins de
monde possible au moment critique les
heures de pointe
ça passe par l'organisation du
télétravail ça a bien marché
hier et nous organisons comme vous le
savez un système d'attestation qui
permettra de réguler le nombre de
voyageurs aux heures de pointe et
ensuite monsieur le député nous avons
pris des mesures fortes sur le plan
sanitaire
vous l'avez dit vous-même nous avons
imposé le port du masque est plus de 95%
meyer 98 % aujourd'hui
des voyageurs avaient un masque ou s'en
sont vu doter un notamment avec l'effort
de l'état des deux millions de masques
que nous avons distribué partout en
france depuis hier pendant près de
soixante jours tous les soirs les
français ont applaudi leurs soignants
mais comment donner suite à cet élan de
solidarité
christophe blanchet député la république
en marge du calvados à une proposition
pour la ministre du travail écouter
notre devoir est d'interpréter cette
demande de fraternité et de lui donner
forme à cet effet madame la ministre
nous en avons adressé il ya trois
semaines avec 100 députés de la majorité
une proposition offrir la possibilité
pour les salariés qui le veulent dans le
public comme dans le privé de faire don
d'une partie de leurs congés payés ou
rtt au bénéfice de ceux qui lui
directement contre le coc vide 19
ce dispositif n'est pas une charge
supplémentaire pour les tares ni pour
les entreprises car ces congés sont déjà
provisionné ainsi récupérées sur acte
uniquement de volontariat il constitue
une somme qui serait redistribué sous
forme de chèques vacances nous
permettrions au personnel soignant
lorsqu'ils prendront quelques jours de
congé bien mérité de profiter de bons
moments supplémentaires partager en
famille dans un restaurant un hôtel
amusé un parc de loisirs ou autre à
titre indicatif
si chacun des 23 millions de salariés en
france donne juste un
de séjour alors ce serait deux milliards
d'euros consommer dans notre économie
touristique locale et nationale
madame la ministre qu'elle suit le
gouvernement entend donner à cette
proposition solidaire au tant sociale
qu'économique
porté par les députés de la majorité
évidemment on ne sait pas quelle est
l'ampleur de ce que ça pourra
représenter ça dépendra du volontariat
mais c'est intéressant aussi le couple
est avec les chèques vacances comme vous
le proposez puisque c'est aussi le
tourisme un secteur qui est en
difficulté et c'est une manière jeu de
jouer collectif à la fois pour la santé
mais aussi pour le secteur du tourisme
donc au tour du gouvernement je peux
vous confirmer que je soutiens
pleinement votre proposition que nous
allons travailler ensemble sur les
modalités de son exécution
il faut définir les modalités de
conversion des jours de repos
une somme d'argent il faut gérer le
dispositif où les modalités de
répartition entre les bénéficiaires
enfin ça soulève toute une série de
questions mais quand on a la volonté
on y arrive et je pense qu'on est dans
une crise exceptionnelle et toutes les
innovations doivent être encouragées
voilà pour le débrief des questions au
gouvernement cette semaine quasi
exclusivement consacré aux déconfinement
qui a eu lieu ce lundi
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau débrief